and the turmoil continues in ottawa
today not only is there a new man at the
helm of the city's police service we're
also getting new insight into the
emergencies acts and how it could be
used to end the relentless downtown
protests of course a lot of questions
with more on everything going on abigail
beamon joins us from ottawa abigail
great to see you so
this was invoked on monday follow the
timeline for a moment so here we are on
wednesday
a little more clarity what more do we
know well finally late last night you
know we've been clamoring for actual
details of what was in there and the
text of the emergencies act was released
late last night there was also a
technical briefing going over some of
the details with reporters that happened
before they had even released the text
so lots of confusion over over this
whole thing but a couple of standout
notes after i've gone through and
actually read the wording in here one
thing that had not been made clear until
late yesterday or last night is that the
emergency act regulation has a lot in
there about minors about children about
how it is now not okay to travel to uh
what the government terms to be an
illegal occupation or protest with a
minor or to have a minor present another
thing and we spoke we did speak about
this yesterday but some more clarity
around tow trucks uh the government
directing tow trucks to uh to tow
vehicles if they don't want to do it uh
officials saying that you know it's a
complicated situation but suggesting
that they would have the ability to take
over those tow trucks and and and use
government officials to to do the towing
if a company did not want to do that and
then of course the biggest piece of the
puzzle here in terms of finances still
not so clear in terms of what what banks
need to do uh
crowdfunding platforms and
cryptocurrency having to
report to register with fintrac all of
those elements are still becoming clear
you know we've been asking the banks all
day yesterday in the canadian banking
association for a statement about how
they're going to enforce this or the
consequences and you still don't see
that yet as everybody's trying to figure
this out but of course we can't ignore
the reaction as well a lot of political
reaction from the opposition a number of
provinces and premiers have uh opposed
this so far and then there are the legal
questions of course whether this meets
the threshold but before all this going
back to the politics this has to be
before this is confirmed this has to be
voted on and it has to be approved so
what is the timeline how does that work
exactly what is the timeline
yeah a lot of uh process questions here
so uh the understanding is that this has
to be tabled in the house within seven
days uh there's gonna be time to to
debate it and then vote on it uh but
it's not that it has to be voted on
within seven days the state the
emergencies act is in place it has been
triggered uh but it needs to be tabled
in the house within seven days uh and my
understanding is that once it's tabled
uh the debate needs to happen by the
next day uh and and if at any point
either the house or the senate which
both need to vote on this if they vote
against the emergencies act uh then it's
it's it's some word around negative
negative if that's the word it's it's
it's uh it's no longer in force uh if
that happens but so within these seven
days that needs to be tabled and then
you'll see debate on it and see what the
politicians have to say so still a lot
of questions there obviously but then
there's the big news of the ottawa's
police chief um
resigning whether that was willingly or
pushed out nonetheless he is going to be
well he's gone so peter's slowly out of
the job they have a new interim police
chief what does that mean for the
overall
really the plan moving forward and
really their goal to move the protesters
out of the downtown core
yeah well that's the billion dollar
question so last night or not last night
yesterday afternoon the police services
board met they heard from the new
interim chief that's a steve bell he was
deputy police chief before
every single member is asking him what's
the plan what's the plan what's the plan
uh and uh the interim chief bell is says
that there is a plan he promises that
ottawa police have a plan they're
working on it they're working to refine
it and he'll let the police services
board know uh behind closed doors you
know when it's ready to activate because
he doesn't want to give
information publicly about that plan but
again this is day 20 and a lot of people
frustrated uh that that this is the
point that things are at right now and
and with the police chief gone a lot of
questions about you know how that that
leadership vacuum will fill in and what
will happen we heard from the public
safety minister uh yesterday talking
about the integrated command center and
he was suggesting that opp ontario
provincial police and the rcmp with this
new structure with the integrated
command center between the three of them
that those police forces are in a
position to command and control uh as
well so still waiting for details in
terms of how this all plays out i will
point out that there has not been a
media opportunity to ask ottawa police
any questions since friday we are
wednesday now we are expecting to hear
uh from council late this afternoon okay
so you you point out the leadership
questions when it comes to the police
service but a lot of questions and
criticism of the leadership at all
levels of government they are not immune
to this and of course to be continued on
that but in terms of today what more do
we expect
uh a few things so you'll remember uh
perhaps view viewers will remember the
honking
and how there was a court injunction in
place that called for an end to the
honking we've you know seen occasional
honking but nothing like those first
days where it was just non-stop and and
people were not sleeping for days uh on
end uh and so those lawyers are back in
court today because the court granted a
10-day injunction that's set to expire
lawyers will argue
to extend that for the resident's sake
here in the city so we're watching that
today we're watching as i mentioned uh
the council meeting this afternoon we
haven't heard from the mayor uh
in a number of days either so looking
for an update there and then of course
watching to see if anything develops on
the hill in terms of uh when the
emergencies act will be tabled and and
some debate to get underway